oddio cosa in combinato per me questa è
solo oggi ma challenge slime rosa contro
prime time solo con cose rosa infatti
sono timorose e io sembro quindi come
emoziona chi vince tra pizze chi riesce
a fare lo slime più rosa nel mio caso ho
più blu
nel suo caso perché perché mi pescheremo
ognuna di queste cose da bendati ma
alcune di queste cose non sono rosa
dentro o blu potrebbero essere bianchi o
potrebbero essere di altri colori
riguardante il video fino alla fine
perché poi dovrete votare se vinco io
timoroso ne vince vitale fino in base
allo tra i fedeli comodi lasciate un bel
mi piace se questo video raggiunge i 10
mila vi piace la facciamo col terrore
perché io perde qualche meglio marrone
che ti mancano poi i colori della
prossima sfida di colori challenge
quindi scrivete nei commenti che altri
colori volete che facciamo bene rigori
parati report corre in senso allora
andiamo a bendarsi ea pescare a ti
aspetta casi sono questi 25 dominato
soprattutto accaduto qualcosa al rumore
sul mercato io ho pescato però cambiato
pescato il trio compreso latina
e toccato ma adesso è questo tipo che ho
toccato
vediamo adesso se no no non puoi barare
perché altrimenti magari dalla forma
riesce a capire cos'è
quindi se nel primo che pescato io ho
preso delle palline rosa il nostro trend
e trasparente così si vedranno ancora
meglio i colori e le decorazioni quindi
andiamo a perdere le nostre prime
discussioni
ecco con le mie due da cadute alle mie
perline e quindi diventerà una sorta di
craxi non lo so spero solo che una volta
attivo non casa in questo caso mai è
andata bene perché sono veramente rosa
vediamo ora quelle di vita li diamo se
tu vai 29 quindi state infatti fortunato
perché poteva essere di un altro colore
tipo bianco che te lo rovina va un
pochino verde trasparente quindi
l'ulteriore bianca al buon profumo un ok
sei grande round andiamo perché non c'è
un attimo perché adesso dai vado la ho
preso questo io ho preso questo crediamo
compreso dei sono tre falli avendo idee
ce le abbiamo preso questo ciò che è un
po rosa ma non tanto rosa sembra un po
il rosso quindi andiamo a vedere come
nello slam caso scolarli e shampoo ma
colore rosa ma morto
chiaro quindi finora il mio club non è
molto rosea
proviamo missione bisogna si sono tutte
depositate nel fondo e niente finora non
è molto rosa al mio slime speriamo di
beccare qualcosa che gli dia un bel
colore
io invece il mio invece è rimasto ancora
trasparente non c'è storia che migliori
ecco allora ci sono le decorazioni
questi ci sono se le paillettes che i
pallini vajente pallidi si chiama ne
faccio in questo fortunato ma su tutto
ma io e rosa dei pallini deve essere a
crearsi anche questo abbia tutto e
maglietta senza ballini deve bere
abbiamo il bisogno i bambini sono i
pallini dell'indagato ei bar che impresa
ed è un peccato non dovevo ok allora
pesco anch'io ti ho perso tantissimo che
tutti e tre romani speriamo che sia
bianca a vendermi vediamo allora ecco il
mio bagno schiuma rosati è un pò liquido
questo benissimo però almeno rosa quindi
speriamo che il colore rimanga vediamo
mischiava scritto perché allora non è un
rosa proprio molto intenso e un rosa
super chiaro però almeno è diventato un
po rosa il mio
vediamo ora è quello di vitale e già
sono le pagliette al momento che anche
vedo l'ora di vederlo diventare bianca
che vedremo mai niente eh lo so chissà
se vincerò io penso challenge speriamo
ultimo il proprio amore ciao ma non so
perché mi sembra che stia diventando
bardolino forse solo una mia impressione
ma vignola il figlio piu rosa sarebbe
viva ha preso preso anch'io
vediamo è un tubetto spero di non aver
preso di nuovo lo che romani
ma perché tu puoi subito cambiare il
bianco il blu così bici caro mese o dei
pigmenti che sono un po particolare mi
piaceva utilizzato speriamo con la il
mio pigmento rosa e vivo sicura che
diventerà rosa a meno che non mi capita
qualche altro colore strano vediamo come
diventa in più penso che diventerà un po
di glee perché quel bagno schiuma la
diluito un bel po wow
il colore bellissimo sto diventando
metallizzato e viva forte o qualche
possibilità di vincere questa challenge
a vediamo come diventa quella di vitale
adesso è colato un po di slide bona
vediamo il suo come diventare lasciatemi
tranquillo
vincerò da credenti in prigione e ti
prego di giunta ovviamente no l'ho
mandata allo stadio da sgarbi e phil ha
preso un po di colonna veramente bello
ed è pure profumato
il mio è decisamente più rosee un rosa
molto intenso e già pescato già pescato
cosa in combinato preso molto libero mai
visto bergamo nutriente che un po vorrei
che sia bianco e lo shampoo nutriente
vuol dire che si inoltra cioè lui ma non
posso possa essere nutriente che i
ragazzi meta bronzo
ecco qua lo shampoo vediamo di che
colore
bianco trasparente
speriamo che non rovini colore del mio
slime omi 7 crostis chiarendo un po anzi
ancora meglio perché sembrava rosso più
che rosa quindi per fortuna non è andata
male
vediamo ora quella di vitale è un
peccato capitale perché avevo io
[Musica]
non si vedono ma sarò bellissima
brillanti anche se è fortunato sono
proprio curioso di vedere come the sly
motivata krancic ostacoli per ultimo
duro quindi speriamo che ci capiti
qualcosa di buono e che non rovinino
tema all ultimo momento che avete già
pescando va via
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cos'è 20 m 1 gb con una volta che
cos'è non semplicemente bellissima lo so
compagni stima che questo c'è le bolle
d'ossigeno grazie oppure avrà un sacco
d'aria frontline mollare fate questo
pigmento ha un colore molto particolare
un rosa super super deal è uno stronzo
ma che terre bellissimo sui social
troviamo che scavo berlino berlino e
suoni in giardino che rincorre le
formiche gli insetti e l'erba che bene
la fine diventato un color stupendo
vediamo come diventa il tuo con questo
bagnoschiuma all'ossigeno voglio proprio
vedere ok
prendiamo il colore e so già che non
sarà molto forte
infatti tra che suoni faranno ciao ciao
mi chiamo tutto bene
ha fatto cadere qualcosa questo anche tu
il glitter io non sono sicurezza si
abilitano con l'acqua da una colla forse
colla glitterata vediamo avviene più
coabitiamo la nostra con la letterata
cos'è ma non serve ha detto di cacchetta
di berlino ha mangiato tutto la fragola
è scomparsa non lo slime ai da qualche
parte il mostro di loch ness
basta quando la tim e rossi vedrà
sicuramente ma terribile questa cosa
forse stava nel negozio da tanti anni e
si rinsecchita diventerà ancora più
bello poter decidere che ha vinto
l'italia aveva dati dei glitter e poi
mischiamo è adesso il momento è topico
vedremo profonda che attivo arrivo del
momento di attivare i nostri treni
il sito enorme o 33 su per lotti su per
l'ici lucido busi lo è neanche un
booking di glee e cliccare mi piace
tantissimo quella di più bel colore e
come te visto che proprio blog
ora andiamo a sentire un po di suoni e
morbidissimo
[Musica]
a me piace un sacco voi cosa ne pensate
vediamo ora quello di vitale vediamo se
quello di vitale è più blu del bureau de
bellis e un celestino chiaro però non è
proprio una guarda quanti diritto di
rito rimini sono le paillettes e 8 bella
poi vediamo nelle zone per ora tentiamo
[Musica]
di non male effettivamente ok allora
facciamo la pizza
impostiamo il padre i brillantini le
pezze di pezzettini che sembrano lo
svizzero batte morbido però non sono
tutti profumatissimi e dà tutto ma il
bagnoschiuma ci credo allora dovete
votare chi mise il mio rota oi celestino
di evitare votate io voto berlino come
perché questa dormendo tranquillamente
da fuori un visto adesso basta una fonte
di bello che le paga che bello che
rifare tutto intatto il sondaggio de
vincenti bravo e spingerebbe ricordatevi
pensare un mi piace perdurate per vedere
altri talenti con altre sonori e ora vi
lasciamo un pò a quattro cartellini su
cui cliccare prevedere altri video
quando si sa mai come finché clown e te
non possiamo farlo aggiunge soggiorni
scoperto paralizza parole per chitarra
che per sbarrare penalizza tutte e due
che cosa nostra che dite
perché
da scoprire
vai a cagare